something of a moment uh adam because
you know one of the ways of measuring
whether we're in a wave of covert
19 is to look at what's happening to
deaths and how deaths
from all causes compare with the
historical average that's how you find
out whether you've got excess deaths
uh or not and if i just show you the
chart here this this line here shows you
that historical average and we're just
going through
uh from the beginning of last year
through to where we are now
at the moment that's the average the
five-year average from previous years
and here's what happened in 2020 that
very big spike
that you had in the the spring of 2020
and then this slightly smaller spike in
excess deaths that you've seen
in the latest wave and what you can
probably see there if you just look a
little bit closely
you can see that that black line is now
below the white line that means
we are not in a period of excess deaths
for the first time
since september no deaths above the
average it's the same thing i should say
in across the uk because that last chart
was just england and wales but same
thing
if you look across the uk that black
line going below the white line so good
news
uh there but it is just worth saying
when you look at the total number of
people who have died from covert 19
there are various different ways
of measuring it one is looking at the
official government uh
model and that one would suggest that
around 126 000 people
have died of covert 19 over this entire
period if you take to these two
peaks but the ons has a slightly more
comprehensive measure where they look at
the number of deaths
on deaths if it were covered is
mentioned on the death certificate on
that basis
we're now very close to 150 000 deaths
from covert 19.
they measured that earlier peak being
slightly more than the
the other measure because there was less
testing going on at that point
nonetheless good news in the excess
deaths now have come to an end in this
second
peak and some people would say that's a
sign that the second wave is now very
much over